on va parler donc des castors à présent
oui ce week-end la prothèse passe-t-il
avec les castes yonath ça vous à ça vous
interroge ça nous interroge la
traditionnelle au castor est organisée
donc pour en parler sur ce plateau
sandrine tesson c'est mon histoire et et
christophe beaux visages de tous les
deux organisateurs de la course
alors ça me brûle les lèvres pourquoi ne
vient vous vient le nom de nom castor ce
n'est pas une course pour les castors
mais le castor est une est une mascotte
et la mascotte du club du club de de
guyancourt puis en cours orientation 78
et cette mascotte vient sûrement de de
la première carte de course
d'orientation que le club a créé ce sur
ce site là du parc des sources de la
bière
source de la bièvre bièvre beaver en
anglais castor non ça vient de loin on
perd on peut penser de loin
il ya eu des pasteurs et que toujours
est il que le castor est devenu
effectivement la masse un masque à club
et alors au cours de ce week end et
jours de compétition comment ça va se
passer je crois qu'il ya plusieurs
épreuves qui vont être qu'ils vont se
dérouler sur sur les deux jours tout à
fait il ya le samedi une course
d'orientation à vtt qui est organisé et
le dimanche une course d'orientation
pédestre la pds ce sera la onzième
édition cette année
et concernant la course d'orientation à
vtt ce sera la troisième édition cette
année et pour la deuxième année
consécutive on a décidé de combiner les
deux courses et de faire un week end
c'est au pas ce qu'on appelle dans le
jargon des orientations un week end ses
os et on a créé la bio castor donc avec
un classement combiné pour certains
orienteurs qu'ils vont faire deux
épreuves une le samedi et une le
dimanche le bio ça n'a rien à voir avec
l'environnement
si c'est quand même rare quand même fait
on essaye de faire attention de toute
façon là on a quand même des des
impératifs à ce niveau là au niveau de
la fédération et au niveau de l'eau nf
puisque on est quand même sur les terres
de l'eau nf
on a souvent besoin de demander des
autorisations il faut qu'on rentre de la
forêt dans l'état où on la trouvait donc
propre et au que donc il y assez de ces
deux épreuves en vtt il ya quatre
parcours et à pied c'est voit les images
c'est difficile ça glisse c'est
compliqué aussi s'il pleut ce week-end
ça va ça risque de le terrain risque
d'être un petit peu gras effectivement
mais mais ça ne s'arrête pas les
participants peut-être un beau jeu si
les gens veulent se renseigne un peu
plus sur le détail de la course vous
avez un site internet où on peut se
référer tout à fait aux castors
aux castors point org si jamais vous
voulez aller sur internet en tant que
cette émission n'oubliez pas aussi les
réseaux sociaux d'ailleurs pour
commenter le 7 8 le hashtag le 7 8 et
elle alors à part la bio castor il ya la
mini aux castors
alors qu'est ce que c'est la mini aux
castors il s'agit d'un des sept parcours
de de l'épreuve pédestre est donc ce
parcours mini aux castors le dernier-né
on va dire de l'épreuve s'adresse
surtout aux petits aux enfants âgés de 4
à 7 ans accompagnés de leurs parents que
c'est un peu difficile quand même à 4-4
5 ans de faire de l'orientation tout
seul les perdre en forêt et cette année
ce parcours aux mines et aux castors
sera en grande partie urbain sur la
commune de voisins un petit peu en forêt
au 6 mai en grande partie urbain et il
s'apparente assez facilement un jeu de
piste plus qu'à une course d'orientation
il s'agit bien évidemment de ceux de se
déplacer cartes en main mais il ya
quelques activités ludiques à chaque
balise pour rendre la chose encore plus
ludique qu'elle n'ait déjà
justement vous parlez de course ludique
le castor et est ouverte à tous on n'est
pas obligé d'être un pro de la boussole
pour effet que s'aventurer effectivement
donc le dimanche sur l'activité pédestre
on propose sept parcours quatre des sept
parcours sont adaptés à des gens qui ont
déjà
une certaine connaissance de l'activité
qui donc via le faire dans un esprit de
compétition chronométrés et 3,17
parcours dont le mini au castor est lui
plus destiné aux novices et a envie de
découvrir l'activité et pour se mettre
dans le bain je crois que il hier
dimanche vous aviez organisé une petite
initiation pour vraiment faire découvrir
à ceux qui voulaient signifier tout de
suite
tout à fait on propose au moment de
l'inscription sur le site internet on
propose à ce qu'il souhaite faire une
initiation ou en tout cas acquérir un
certain nombre de réflexes de participer
à une séance d'initiation qui a eu lieu
donc hier où il y a eu environ 45
personnes qui sont venues prendre les
premiers conseils qui ont été qui ont
été données et nous organisons aussi une
petite séance d'initiation le jour de la
course le dimanche matin aux alentours
de 8h30 avant le départ pour ceux qui
n'ont pas pu assister à celle d'hier et
qui aurait besoin peut-être aussi d'un
petit un petit réglage supplémentaire
avant le départ de la course
quels sont les bons réflexes pour être
un excellent dans le domaine de
l'orientation alors excellent tout de
suite risque de pas être évident mais
les bons réflexes déjà à savoir lire une
carte et se servir se servir de la de la
boussole en priorité pour pour la
compétition voulais rajouter des choses
que j'avais surtout rajouter de tenir sa
carte dans le bon sens et ça fait bien
ça car ça fait un bon début
beaucoup qui viennent sur la compétition
et qui ne savent pas qu'ils prennent la
carte à l'envers et vous voyez parti ça
vous arrive comment ils vont arriver que
même quand on est un
un orienteur aguerris on va dire il nous
arrive de malencontreusement faire une
erreur stupide de tenues de cartes à
l'envers et donc de s'éloigner de la
balle en plus que c'est une carte
spéciale c'est pas les cartes michelin
ou les cartes routières contre merci
anthony pour cette marque
les cartes routières qu'on trouve à la
commercer et secte il s'agit il s'agit
billet il s'agit bien d'une carte très
détaillée beaucoup plus détaillé qu'une
qu'une carte ign sur laquelle est passée
un cartographe qui a qui a recensé
toutes les dépressions tout les buts
tous les chemins tous les sentiers qui a
fait aussi des relevés de végétation
donc quelque chose de très très détaillé
et il reste encore des places on peut
s'inscrire
oui on pense par ci vous permet non non
c'est pas fermé il reste un certain
nombre de places sur certains circuits
donc les inscriptions sont encore
ouvertes jusqu'au 14 novembre environ et
actuellement nous sommes à peu près à 8
140 inscrits sur la course du dimanche
et 230 inscrits sur la course du samedi
au vtt je vous laisse encore le temps
d'apprendre à lire une carte en temps
voilà exactement
j'ai encore quelques jours avant d'être
tellement de m'initier merci beaucoup
d'être venu sur plateau télé fils ce
soir et puis donc rendez vous samedi et
dimanche pour cette superbe course qui
s'annonce merci à vous tous et bienvenu
merci à tous les deux on poursuit cette
page de sport dans un instant deux
autres invités on va parler de judo
rencontres internationales 20e
anniversaire pour les rencontres
internationales de trappes auparavant de
l'escrim oui oui cette semaine je suis
allé à la rencontre de cédric heineken
et de jéromine enpa j'engage j'essaye de
ne pas écorcher le mans fait ces noms
vous disent peut-être rien mais il
pourrait bien être la relève de
l'escrimé française qui a connu un gros
gros fiasco pendant les derniers jeux
olympiques de londres portraits croisés
réalisé avec valérie olibeau
ils sont sûrement l'avenir de l'escrim
française à gauche de la piste je rumine
une panne j'en garde à droite cédric
heineken est champion de france junior
à 19 ans ils ont choisi deux voies
différentes mais avec une même arme le
fleuret pour atteindre le haut niveau
cédric l'est resté fidèle à trappes et
continue ses études à l'université de
versailles saint quentin
ils pointent désormais au 25e rang
mondial pour sa dernière saison junior
jéromine elle a intégré le pôle espoir
féminin français à aix en provence à
l'âge de 15 ans et prépare le concours
de sciences po par correspondance de
systèmes d'entraînement et de vie qui
n'ont qu'un seul but
intégrez l'équipe de france en vue des
jeux olympiques de 2016 où tous les ans
je mens je pense pas puisque
l'importance quand même les seniors
essaie de rentrer à 17,7 soja plus que
réussie de notre escapade entraîneurs
nationaux trade ça j'essaie de ne pas
trop me prendre la tête
je travaille pour l'étude des français
air pour pour avoir des titres pour tous
depuis le cataclysme des derniers jeux
olympiques de londres où l'équipe de
france est rentrée bredouille
la fédération française est en plein
chantier les changements qui pourraient
profiter aux jeunes espoirs trappistes
ils portent elles sont ouvertes maison
des choix à faire dans dans leur vie
voilà est-ce qu'ils veulent faire du
haut niveau ça demande des sacrifices
ils le savent qu'ils prennent leur
destin en main quoi s'est ouvert à rien
de fermer et s'ils sont bons et et s'ils
le méritent les places elle arrivons
maintenant c'est du travail peut se
passer plein de chose quoi il peut se
passer une blessure il peut se passer
ça marche pas une année à la base
c'était pas gagné pour l'équipe soit la
dame devait pas partir j'ai donc c'est
un super bon point qu'il soit parti et
qu'elle vous fait 4e c'est pas avant pas
ces dernières de la compet en même temps
et pour nous les jeunes ça ne s'annonce
pas nous tous à redoubler d'efforts pour
pour apprendre pour apporter d'autres
mais des médailles aux prochains jo je
pense qu'il y aura du changement
du coup je pense que si je mets
débrouillage jusqu'au jo je pense que
j'ai mes chances
après vous cas comme dans la conférence
à copé pour ses joueurs sont prêts pour
compléter je vais tout faire pour cédric
et germyn savent que l'avenir se joue
maintenant pour cela il s'inspire des
meilleurs tireurs mondiaux en effectuant
des stages aux côtés des champions du
monde italiens
c'est sûrement cette ouverture qui
permettra aux espoirs tricolores de
comprendre les exigences du haut niveau